alors ce social de montréal en direct
ses bons jours à montréal bonsoir la
planète ces munitions comme thème canada
en direct donc de montréal ça me semble
assez évident est ici autour de la table
on a des invités des animateurs des
réalisateurs de radio canada
international on charge les choses à
chaque semaine dans le bas de noël ya
toujours des surprises
marie claude simard bonjour comment des
marteaux bonjour bonjour et samir ben
pour la première fois depuis un mois
alors vous avez eu vent du sujet des
missions en prenant connaissance il ya
quelques instants en ondes de l'identité
d'un de nos événements aujourd'hui donc
je vais pas participer au challenge de
débuts au défi de début certainement
parce que je l'aimé je l' ai vu une fois
dans une assistée à une de ses
conférences une fois l'an passé mais on
connaît pas le sujet alors vidéo pour
seulement deux personnes ici un studio
et pour le reste de la planète c'est la
même chose sur la même vidéo on joue on
regarde cinq images vous devenez le
sujet de la démission aimons et
marie-claude faut être précis
une manifestation sur la piste l'extrême
droite
bon oui mais encore confrontation
beaucoup de remarques à nay le
néonazisme ouais sens bien
oui bon à l'homosexualité propositions
de l'opposition
comment battre les extrêmes est là et
c'est à dire qu'on va essayer de
comprendre aujourd'hui comment les
combattre les extrémistes quant à lucien
comprendre leur argument est enceinte de
mieux les comprendre parce que le
problème qu'on a en société de plus en
plus on le constate par la présence de
certains médias en ont notamment ce qui
se passe sur le web c'est qu'on a des
points de vue très arrêtées qui se
nourrissent eux un peu l'un de l'autre
va laisser son état qu'on n'essaie pas
de comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
tête des autres on est bien mal parti je
pense pour essayer de régler nos
problèmes l'ancien président portent sa
venue à la tête des coûts
alors on joue encore une fois cette
semaine
il ya votre votre mardi à votre
réputation est en jeu
trois jeux à l'émission oui c'est quoi
ça oui faire parler tous ces noms vous
pouvez faire ce que vous avez alors
combien dijon un gain normalement vous
aviez sans boule à perdre dans chaque
émission catalan et 3 jeux mais vous
trichez on le sait on ne sait jamais qui
a perdu ses boules
alors on oscille stéphane alors j'ai
réduit on va faire un peu de bruit
j'espère voilà vous perdez vos fesses
elle vous fait passer direct un travail
collectif injecter un show ni maintenant
premier jeu qui veut actionner la grosse
boule et la régie je vous ai gardé des
jetons également vous pouvez jouer jean
plusieurs dons qu'ils ont toujours la
bonne réponse mais on va voir on va voir
certains pays comme l'autriche l'extrême
droite participent parfois ou pour
l'édition gouvernementale on sait avec
les partis de droite les partis de
centre droite et possède donc à
l'occasion des ministres au sein d'un
cabinet dans lequel de ces pays une
telle alliance ne s'est jamais encore
produite
demain - récente évidemment s à israël b
la norvège
c'est le danemark ou encore ce que
j'adore toujours le d aucune de ces
réponses
la norvège se diraient non mais je dis
danemark danemark c'est vous allez dire
israël
alors vous allez tous ajouté si aucune
en or on ne renonce jamais la régie
c'est vous qui le savaient pas c'est
aucune de ces réponses dans l'île
là vous l'avez pas vu l'arrivée galloway
s'en sort à bon soyons si vous n'êtes
pas honnête si vous dites pas que faire
avec ce joueur maître de leur personne
n'avait à peu près aucun de ces noms
c'est le canada aucune séance de voeux
tous ces pays ont eu des coalition avec
l'extrême droite au pouvoir
internationale alors on va aller vers
nos invités parce que je sens qu aucun
endroit d'où est née mais des
spécialistes de la question approuvez on
l'a prouvé
de tous des gens de gauche c'est bien
connu alors on a des torts et c'est au
fus quant au feu rouge pour un peu trop
c'est raide gauche va faire là alors
david morin professeur université de
sherbrooke au directeur d'observatoire
sur la radicalisation et l'extrémisme
violent bonjour professeur vous êtes en
compagnie d'aurélie campana que vous
connaissez très bien vous vous êtes
complémentaires au niveau de vos
connaissances et madame campana et
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université laval et les spécialistes
de l'extrême droite
bonjour la campagne bonjour alors
écoutez j'aimerais quand même qu'on
parle de l'éléphant qui est sur le
balcon dans les points de vue d'extrême
droite et le jeu je suis à la recherche
d'une définition de ce que c'est
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite avec la
création ou l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux
j'aimerais comprendre je sais qu'à
plusieurs on l'a vu dans les campagnes
politiques de trompe il ya beaucoup de
citoyens qui pensent d'une certaine
manière et
qui partagent certains points de vue des
radicaux de droite mais qui ne veulent
pas aller jusque là il ya un embarras et
on le sent ça dans la population même
québécoise par exemple sur les questions
d'immigration des points de vue partagé
par l'extrême droite mais qui ne sont
pas acceptés les moyens d'action vous ne
sont pas acceptés par tous même la même
manière quelle est la situation
précisément au québec parlons de ce qui
est très proche de nous de cette
présence de l'extrême droite fait nous
en un portrait on va commencer avec
monsieur campana mais pas tant que ça
quand on va commencer avec madame leurs
campagnes parce que je passe avec elle
qu'on voulait commencer ni sa première
réflexion pour commencer avec à votre
question qui est très vaste
c'est qu'il est très difficile d'aboutir
à une définition consensuelle de ce
qu'est l'extrême droite et qui a une
distinction minimale à faire entre des
partis politiques que l'on qualifie
d'extrême droite
vous jouez le jeu parlementaire de jeu
politique
quelquefois pour essayer d'en changer
les règles de l'intérieur et des groupes
des groupuscules que l'on va qualifier
d'extrême droite est de plus en plus
pour certains d'ultra droite et
j'expliquerai cette nuance plus tard qui
eux sont évoluent hors du champ
politique ou à la marche du champ
politique et qui vont tenter de
s'affirmer comme des groupes de casinos
been dirais-je pour faire passer un
certain nombre d'idées idée que l'on
associe bien souvent à l'extrême droite
et qui sont liées à tout ce qui relève
du débat identitaire du débat sur
l'immigration sur l'intégration des
nouveaux arrivants
attention ce ne sont pas des débats qui
sont exclusifs à l'extrême droite et
depuis les années 80 on voit bien qu'en
europe les partis politiques
traditionnels de droite ou de gauche
s'empare de ces de ces débats là mais il
n'en reste pas moins que pour des partis
et des groupes d'extrême droite ce sont
des questions absolument centrale alors
qu'en est-il au québec
au québec il me semble pouvoir dire
qu'on a fois deux partis politiques
d'extrême droite en revanche ont émergé
dans les années
récemment un certain nombre de groupes
que l'on peut identifier clairement la
meute pour ne pas la nommer ce temps mme
alliance et bien d'autres groupes qui
ont acquis une certaine visibilité dans
l'espace public en organisant des
manifestations en utilisant abondamment
les médias sociaux c'est pas un
phénomène nouveau il existe des groupes
et des groupuscules d'extrême droite
depuis longtemps au québec mais il
n'était pas aussi visibles qu'ils le
sont aujourd'hui
et il y a une grande variation dans la
nature de ces groupes il y en a
effectivement qui sont des groupes qui
peuvent paraître avoir un discours
relativement modérée en public qui est
un discours beaucoup plus dur quand il
s'adresse directement leurs militants
qui appartiendrait à ce que l'on
pourrait nommer l'alt wright ou c'est à
dire cette droite alternative ou même
une droite alternative beaucoup plus
molle qui a pour objectif de se rendre
visible et de devenir légitimement
acceptable dans l'espace public
et il ya des groupes beaucoup plus
radicaux qui prône des modes d'action
beaucoup plus radicaux qui en appelle
par exemple à l'arrêt immigration des
immigrants est ce que ces groupes ont du
succès plus de succès aujourd'hui où on
parle plus d'eux
relis je pense que l'extrême droite
n'est pas un phénomène il tellement
nouveau dans l'histoire de l'europe
évidemment il évoque une sorte de les
lire mais dans les dernières années à la
faveur d'un certains nombres contexte je
dirais qu'il a pris de l'essor alors
c'est contexte que c'était quoi c'est
évidemment la lutte contre le terrorisme
djihadiste qui est venu nourrir
finalement un certain nombre de groupes
sur l'existence d'un ennemi extérieur
avoir d'un ennemi intérieur donc
évidemment ça a nourri beaucoup le
discours islamophobe
l'autre élément a été la crise
économique en 2008
en europe c'est peut-être traduit un peu
moins fortement que aux états unis mais
elle a quand même eu des échecs et puis
les crises ou les défis migratoires
finalement associés au conflit notamment
en syrie et en irak les donc si vous
voulez c'est ces éléments là
dernièrement évidemment l'élection de
monsieur trump sont venues alimenter ces
groupes-là leur donner beaucoup de grain
à moudre et leur ont permis dans une
certaine mesure d'occuper davantage
l'espace public
et c'est vrai que il y a eu quand même
une couverture médiatique intense de ces
groupes là par exemple avec les
attentats de la mosquée de québec plus
récemment avec les attentats en nouvelle
zélande qui leur permettent finalement
c'est un peu paradoxal plus on essaye
d'expliquer à eux ces groupes l'un plus
on donne aussi à la frange la plus
radicale
une certaine visibilité donc oui
indiscutablement je dirais que il y à
une montée de l'extrême droite et
d'extrême droite la plus radicale en
occident au moins au cours des dernières
semaines
alors on a beaucoup de questions ici
autour de la table d'abord samir ben moi
je vous ai posé une question à monsieur
morin et madame campagne est ce que les
groupes de droite de au québec c'est un
s'abreuve à
aux mêmes sources que l'extrême droite
en europe par exemple journée savoir est
ce que c'est les mêmes sources où elles
vont chercher leur argumentaire où on a
une droite une extrême-droite spécifique
au québec
si je peux peut-être d'avis que tu
complétera je dire ça dépend du groupe
chaque groupe va constituer son discours
idéologique autour de références qu'ils
vont aller chercher à droite à gauche
certains groupes vont directement
s'abreuver en europe d'autres vont à
tendance à se tourner dans les états
unis mais il ya une circulation dans
certains discours d'un certain nombre de
thèses théorie du complot qui sont
réinvestis pour la plupart des gros
maintenant il ya peut-être une
spécificité québécoise qui est propre à
certains groupes de l'extrême droite ou
de l'ultra droite qui vont tenter de
réinvestir le débat souverainiste et
certains groupes se posent directement
comme des défenseurs de la souveraineté
qu'ils associent de plus en plus
d'ailleurs à un nécessaire retour du
christianisme et à nécessaire
réinvestissement de la religion dans
l'espace public
donc si on lections compare les coûts
québécois aux autres groupes canadiens
parce qu'il ya des groupes
d'extrême-droite ailleurs au canada
c'est peut-être la spécificité qui va
marquer certains d'entre eux mais pas la
majorité d'entre eux parce que pour la
plupart le débat souverainiste n'est pas
un débat structurants ce qu'ils
entendent défendre d'abord et avant tout
c'est cette fameuse majorité blanche
silencieuse entre guillemets
marie-claude oui ça va sembler un peu
curieux comme question comme à votre
connaissance les groupes que vous
qualifier d'extrême droite est ce qu'ils
se qualifient eux-mêmes l'extrême-droite
comme les groupes de gauche qui se
qualifie joyeusement et ouvertement de
gauche et d'extrême gauche
est ce que l'extrême droite ça fait
d'écouter ma jambe droite non évidemment
ils refusent ce qualificatif infamant
non évidemment le grand débat entre les
chercheurs peut-être les les faiseurs
d'opinion ces groupes-là qui précisément
prennent soin ne pas se qualifier
d'extrême droite d'où l'essor et puis je
laisserais pourrait vite être développée
là dessus mais de termes comme
l'ultra droite ou alors la droite
alternative et c'est parce que
effectivement le qualificatif d'extrême
droite en europe a une connotation
extrêmement marqués et d'ailleurs même
un groupe comme de front national je
suis très content pour soulever les gens
qui le catégoriser comme un parti de
droite
donc évidemment non les groupes ne
veulent pas vous vous est évidemment moi
je trouve pas ça c'est évident je pense
que c'est important de réaliser que
l'extrême droite c'est une étiquette que
c'est déjà ne choisissent pas de
s'imposer mais qu'on choisit de leur a
posé je ne sais pas du tout de créditer
ces groupes là mais c'est quand même
c'est comme vous utilisez une
connotation très négatif pour extrême
droite et dont dix ont lieu comme une
connotation très positive dans le
langage pour la gauche
je dis juste comme ça pourquoi pas
toujours pour l'extrême gauche parce que
l'on a par décret mais par contre qu'ils
ne refusent pas comme comme la belle
c'est vous êtes des groupes d'opposition
alors des groupes oppositionnel parce
que derrière le discours anti musulmans
le discours anti immigration
derrière ces idées centrales qui forment
le coeur de ses discours là il ya de
plus en plus un discours anti élites
antisystème et anti gouvernement
il en a trop tendance à l'oublier je
pense quand on parle d'extrême droite
ultra droite et c'est une partie du
discours qui commence à devenir de plus
en plus saillante danse pour certains
groupes d'extrême droite au canada mais
également au québec on voit joindre
aussi le libertarien presque dans ce
contexte delà ce ces 10,1 qu'on parle
des fils d'odin de la même date l'an
tout
de la nation à rien et j'en passe dans
tous les cas on parle essentiellement de
du blancs de souche européenne
alors qu'ici il ya une place de plus en
plus à l'avant scène qui est en train de
se faire
pour nous les premières nations pour les
autochtones
quelle réponse à ton assez quelles
réponses offre ces gens là par rapport
aux autochtones
quand on parle de l'immigration et de
priorités dublin alors ça dépend des
groupes certains groupes vont inclure
moins longtemps dans ce que j'ai vu dans
les recherches que j'ai faites vont
inclure les autochtones comme étant des
peuples aborigènes donc ne vont pas
forcément les cibler par contre il ya
d'autres groupes qui ne vont se
concentrer sur ce qu'ils appellent à la
défense de la majorité blanche et qui
vont inclure les autres codes dans la
catégorie autres c'est à dire ce qu'il
faut qu'il faut combattre et il ya eu
dans en alberta en particulier en
ontario également des actions qui ont
été qui ont ciblé des lieux dans
lesquels se retrouvent des membres de
communautés autochtones
donc il ya une variation assez assez
importante sur la place que les
autochtones devraient occuper d'après
c'est d'après ces groupes et en fonction
des coûts poche question là qui est une
des trames narratives pour lunel ces
groupes d'extrême droite c'est l'espèce
de réification de la nation mais
évidemment la nef nation défini selon
leurs propres termes qui commence à une
certaine période de l'histoire qui
s'arrête à une autre et donc évidemment
il ya un espèce de nation fantasmes et
qui finalement dans la plupart des cas
se résume souvent à la nation blanche
qui est construit bleus pays et c'est ça
on voit quand même que ce soit les états
unis le canada ou l'europe
cet élément la vie nationale cette
espèce de construction imaginaire de la
nation au coeur des discours d'extrême
droite depuis quelques minutes on
diffuse des images de
une manifestation qui avait lieu l'été
dernier qui opposait des gens de faction
très différente de la droite la gauche
et on voit ça souvent aujourd'hui on
voit on a vu ça aux etats unis des
manifestants de la gauche
alé lô lors de cérémonies qui avait été
programmé par les gens de la droite pour
essayer de brasser les camarades et
évidemment ça fait de très belles images
mais ça nous rapproche pas de l'objectif
qui était d'essayer de bien simple de
mieux s'entendre l'aiment bien
s'entendre je sais pas remis de nuces en
temps je pense que c'est quand même
souhaitable qu est ce qui se fait
présentement au plan de notre éducation
oublions les médias là parlons de ce qui
se passe à l'école au perdant de ce qui
se passe dans la vie publique pour
essayer de rapprocher les gens de point
de vue différent parce que moi je suis
né à une époque où quand on n'était pas
d'accord avec quelqu'un on ne sortait
pas le couteau
on a fait pas ici entrait dans la
société avec lg je suis né alors qu'est
ce qui se fait présentement pour
nettoyer les choses pour essayer de nous
amener vers l'objectif qui est de vivre
de se conduire comme des gens avec qui
on de moralité david peut-être que tu
peux parler de rêver oui absolument je
pense que vous soulevez un point
important qui est le phénomène de
polarisation sociale
alors on emploie beaucoup la question
des extrémismes je pense qu'il faudrait
discuter d'abord et avant tout des
polarisation sociale c'est à dire
effectivement de point de vue dans la
société qui ont de plus en plus de mal à
accepter des arguments contradictoires
et qui dans une certaine mesure refuse
le dialogue donc on se retrouve dans une
situation il ya beaucoup de monologues
qui s'entrechoquent les uns les autres
et où effectivement on peine à
confronter les points de vue et à mettre
des arguments les uns en face des autres
ce qui du reste est extrêmement
perceptible sur les réseaux sociaux où
finalement on à la construction de
tribunes numérique et quand quelqu'un ne
fait pas votre affaire vous le bloquer
vous ne voulez plus l'entendre et vous
ne vous alimentez vous ne vous abreuver
finalement qu'avec les arguments que
vous êtes déjà dans une certaine mesure
disposés à entendre
donc ça c'est sûr que le débat
contradictoire et à ses héros des parts
c'est par ce phénomène là donc
maintenant
je pense que l'extrémisme violent lui
d'abord appelle une réponse qui est
sécuritaire je travaille sécurité
nationale je pense qu'il ne faut pas
écarter sa du revers de la main
il ya aujourd'hui en occident un
terrorisme d'extrême droite qui appelle
une réponse sécuritaire il faut que les
pouvoirs publics
de la même manière qu'eux ils se sont
attaqués à la question du jihadisme dans
les dernières décennies doivent
reconnaître le problème de l'existence
d'un terrorisme d'extrême droite écouté
depuis 2011
on pourrais vous citer des attentats qui
sont survenus annuellement en occident
des attentats d'extrême droite depuis la
norvège jusqu'à récemment la nouvelle
zélande en passant par les états unis
l'europe le canada évidemment avec les
attentats de la mafia dans nos classes
dont neuf salles de cours
il faut essayer de tourner ça de manière
positive c'est-à-dire pas arriver avec
des programmes qui dirait qu'on fait de
la lutte à l'extrémisme mais davantage
travailler finalement en prévention
primaire sur des éléments comme la lutte
contre l' ennemi contre le racisme
toute la question effectivement des
cultures religieuses donc il faut
renforcer si vous voulez absolument ces
éléments-là faire une éducation aussi à
l'utilisation des médias parce que comme
vous le soulignez tout à l'heure
malheureusement avec les réseaux sociaux
il ya une diffusion de beaucoup de
théorie de complot on retrouve
d'ailleurs chez tous les extrémismes
c'est assez étonnant de voir comment
l'antisémitisme comment les complots
gouvernementaux et s'est repris de part
et d'autre part tous les extrêmes
qu'avec une choix donc il ya évidemment
beaucoup de travail et de pédagogie à
faire notamment de scolaires mais
également avec les médias samy sa mère
c'est mon mandat je voulais toujours
comparer avec l'europe en europe ici se
sont accommodés d'une présence de
l'extrême droite dans leur parlement
est ce qu'au canada et au québec
l'extrême droite est soluble dans la
démocratie locale
à votre avis et est ce que parfois par
des fois on trouve deux discours delà de
l'extrême droite qui dit fini l'argent
doit parfois politiques de certains
hommes politiques à ce que est ce que ce
serait pas bien de les intégrer dans le
système démocratique
au lieu de nous de les stigmatiser bien
sûr on parle pas de l'extrémisme violent
ça c'est clair que quand vous l'avez dit
il faut une réponse sécuritaire a ça
dans un système uninominal à un tour
c'est ça ma question ben je sais pas
trop comment répondre à votre question
parce que j'ai c'est dur de faire de la
projection sur cette question là le
système canadien se compare très très
mal à la plupart des systèmes européens
si on fait exception du système
britannique on entendu j'ai envie de
vous dire est ce qu'il faudrait pas
répondre à vos questions ce qu'il
faudrait pas les intégrer
il ya effectivement un certain nombre
d'hommes politiques qui tiennent des
discours qui peuvent sembler très
proches de ceux de l'extrême droite
on est quand même loin au canada de ce
qu'on peut observer en europe même si on
a observé tout comme en europe une
droitisation des débats politiques
puis il ya une influence je pense assez
fort de ce qui s'est passé en europe
mais aussi aux états unis et
effectivement les partis politiques
traditionnels de droite et de gauche
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure ce sont
emparés de thèmes centraux au parti
d'extrême droite comme la question des
migrations mais c'est pas quelque chose
de récent en europe
c'est quelque chose qui date du des
années 80 alors est-ce qu'il faut mieux
les intégrer parce que ce que les
recherches en sciences politiques montre
pour ce qui est des pays européens c'est
que quand des partis politiques
d'extrême droite rentrer au sein
d'assemblées nationales ou deux
parlements nationaux bas c'est qu'ils
sont obligés quelquefois de revenir sur
la plupart de leurs promesses
électorales
ils sont également obligés de modérer
quelque peu leurs propos du moins à
l'intérieur de l'enceinte parlement
ce qui ne veut pas dire que en campagne
électorale ou à l'extérieur de cette
enceinte ils ne vont pas reprendre ces
fameux thème classique que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure mais quelque
part ils sont obligés de se fondre dans
le jeu démocratique et certains
l'acceptent volontiers d'autres le font
dans la perspective de faire évoluer ce
jeu démocratique vers quelque chose qui
correspond plus à leurs idéaux
mais ce sont des partis aujourd'hui qui
ont su s'imposer en europe à la faveur
on l'a dit tout à l'heure d'un certain
nombre d'évolutions de crise de débat
également et qui font aujourd'hui
malheureusement dirais-je partie
prenante de ce paysage politique
européen et c'est la même chose aux
états unis en à se battre il reste du
temps pour une dernière question en fait
moi c'était juste comme à faire ce que
l'on aime plan pana pour le sacre à mon
avis à le dire c'est que à la lumière de
ce que vous venez de dire vous me
rappeler une période historique qui me
donne qui me donne froid dans le dos
effectivement effectivement pour ça que
j'ai rajouté malheureusement dans ma
dernière phrase merci ça vient c'est une
excellente question même si on a eu des
difficultés ils répondent à ces cons et
des étudiants que voulez-vous
professeurs et professeures écouter
merci infiniment d'avoir accepté de vous
prêter à ce jeu de l'information ici
avec skype
c'est très apprécié merci beaucoup david
marin de vous être joints à nous
aujourd'hui
alors david et professeur à l'université
de sherbrooke que je rappel il est co
directeur de l'observatoire sur la
radicalisation extrême violence
et puis aurélie campana merci beaucoup à
vous également
merci elle nous parlait de style aval du
vélo québec
spécialiste de l'extrême droite alors
voilà ça c'est pour le point de vue de
nos spécialistes mais il reste encore
beaucoup à découvrir
merci beaucoup merci à la prochaine je
voulais vous présenter notre vidéo
tandis que je vois ça s'appelle fouiller
dans nos archives que nous et ça
fonctionne la page de tan tan canada va
apparaître à peu près une demi heure 45
minutes après la diffusion en direct de
cette émission aujourd'hui vendredi par
les 11h15 on
on a commencé la diffusion donc vers
12h15 autour de ça on va vous proposer
notre page d'accompagnement de cette
émission on va regarder la vidéo numéro
voici ce que vous allez apercevoir dans
sept 7 passes d'accompagnement vous avez
des options pour ceux qui regardent pour
la première fois cette émission sur
youtube sur facebook si vous allez sur
notre site rci net - ca et que vous
aurez le plaisir de regarder ces images
qui s'en viennent dans quelques instants
quand je parle d' option vous pouvez
écoutez maintenant pouvez toujours
écouter mon a regroupé un peu les choses
donc vous pourrez écouter la version
sonore de cette émission mais je vous il
est évidemment à regarder la version
visuelle de cette émission parce que
regarder visuel se tient son renfort
fois suis un type leur truc le rouge
après alors là ça c'est la version
sonore mineo vidéo ces vidéos c'est la
sélection la semaine dernière pour ce
qui est des émissions sont là même la
boule bouffi et ça c'est cette semaine
d'accord je fais une compo j'ai fait je
lui fais n'est composé que ici ça c'est
cette semaine ses dossiers qui
accompagnent notre conversation fait par
tous ici présents sauf vous sa meilleure
course que vous travaillez encore peu à
la section française mais c'est toujours
un plaisir de travailler six en france à
ce sujet alors voilà sont à cliquer sur
mots très technique pour dire bon coin
télé sur une page web
voici un spécialiste de toujours
radicalisation c'est le centre de la
radicale voilà vous le connaissez oui
mais maintenant il a changé de métier il
a changé où il ya eu des problèmes ou
celles d'organismes donc ça date de
damas ne paraît cependant très bien
alors écoutez ça c'est ce que j'ai à
vous poser mais je n'avais pas terminé
il ya aussi une petite vidéo sur cette
vidéo
j'avais ajouté qu'une vidéo sur la vidéo
ouais alors humains et a pas de limite
vidéo on va regarder la vidéo
la suite de la vidéo c'est notre
implication
là je demandais à mary claude de prendre
le relais comment ça fonctionne notre
site est extraordinaire notre
application encore mieux non si vous
voulez surtout nous dire sur le
téléphone d'une écoute et ben c'est une
excellente option vous allez si vous
avez un andré vous allez sur google
aurait cherché radio canada est en
national dans la langue de votre choix
en et en cinq langues donc anglais
français espagnol arabe et chinois et
puis sinon si vous avez à pau savais ta
posture et voilà vous allez trouver nos
émissions live ainsi que tous nos
reportages
ouais ça vaut vraiment la peine samir il
vient toujours à l'école avec sa
tablette
là je vois ça regarde ma montre
maintenant la caméra se passer c'est
l'application
je sais pas c'est moi c'est là où je
suis le jeu c'est pas d'accord c'est
votre bon gars de radio
alors on est prêts pour notre jeu de la
deux grosses boules deuxième jeu vous
avez le plaisir ici non de perdre deux
trois balises et l'isi
on va le faire à polluer alors 3 il en
restait huit là raymond encore moins
c'est ça faites vous un des tops j'en ai
perdu deux derniers jours en prison
la régie on a perdu deux et puis anne
marie claude à la basse alléger la
pression va être appliquée alors c'est
un peu de regret pas coutume on
récapitule ce qu'on a appris à l'école
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui avec les
spécialistes car il est facile d'accuser
tel ou tel groupe d'appartenir à la
droite radicale de l'extrême droite de
coller des étiquettes
dites moi quelle formation politique au
québec il ya maintenant peu avant la
tenue des élections provinciales avaient
prévenu les électeurs de se méfier de la
cac qui a remporté les élections en
octobre dernier
en dix ans le parti de la coalition
avenir québec est un parti de l'extrême
droite
quel parti a dit attention là c'est des
gens d'extrême enfin ce soir je vais
trois ou quatre mêmes
alors est ce que c'est le parti
québécois donc non est ce que c'est le
parti communiste du québec et est ce que
c'est le parti libéral oui oui
ou est ce que c'est le parti québec
solidaire pour moi c'est que le parti
libéral c'est le sais je sais c'est pas
le parti c'est un candidat lundi de ses
vacances je le sais on me dira lé parti
communiste le parti communiste d'accord
et puis vraiment je pense que c'est le
petit même si c'est un candidat qui l'a
dit vraiment rien de garder vos jetons
tout va bien
quatre affaires de nettoyage des choses
comme ça la régie perd trois jetons aux
superpouvoirs s'élabore qui gagne
vraiment la preuve c'est bien vous
besoin reste combien atteint 109 là ok
bah on va jouer au troisième jeu tout de
suite c'est en fait sans attendre on
veut désigner les gagnants rapidement
mais on veut battre lors du dîner mais
trop tard voici alors je peux trouver la
question on marque beaucoup
voici les groupes d'extrême droite ou
adiko nous radical de droite en occident
ont souvent comme point de vue commun le
rejet de l'immigration ça aussi on l'a
appris en cela ils ne sont pas
différents du temps de beaucoup de
citoyens plus au centre qui eux savent
ou comme divisés sur cette question je
sais on est d'accord le préambule ouais
je vous admire à voici la question du
référendum dans un sondage récent de la
firme léger de les croiser quel
pourcentage des québécois se disaient
que l'immigration c'est un problème quel
pourcentage de québécois dans un récent
sondage c'est que l'immigration dans les
conditions actuelles c'est un problème s
à c'est sérieux mais nous on veut le
libellé de la question parce que parfois
autre que la question est à poser
week-end
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec des
migrations et où est ce que c'est un
problème à vos yeux ou est-ce que vous
êtes expert alors à 48 % ont dit c'est
un problème
b 38 % ont dit que c'était un problème
ou ses 28 % ont dit que c'était un
problème je pense 38 courses 28% à 38 %
donc c'est 37 b j mais non par 48%
tandis que c'est un malade à 6 48% 46 38
vêtus pour ça mais entre temps qu'ils
étaient 43 alors qui est gratuite
régis est vraiment vous gardez vos
points les gagnants cette semaine c'est
la région dans tous les bons cas là
c'est magique quand même et où vous avez
comme maintenant 5 ans reste combien
croix parfait donc devant vous à reste
beaucoup vous les avez tous jetés au
début qui voulait écrire à huit comptes
et ça paraît alors on est prêt pour
l'image de la semaine
ces quelques jours marc a fait le
sondage vous irez chercher sa mère et
sondage léger sans un journal par contre
quand je vous enverrai la référence à ce
que fait la manchette en tant qu'image
cette mlg
je répond par oui ou par non est-ce que
c'est au canada c'est au canada est donc
cette page
maman des affaires je ne peu partout ce
pas je sais ça fait en ontario
non pas du tout l'ouest canadien n'ont
pas du tout québec
oui à quéven et au québec les taxis ça
peut être l'histoire des taxis qui
manifestent contre une guerre non c'est
pas le cas on vraiment la crise
le site et ses divers la laïcité laurent
gaza crucifix de l'assemblée nationale
déplacés enfin il veut placer et vous
savez que maurice duplessis ancien
premier ministre du québec appelé le
salon bleu le nom originel du salon bleu
non le salon de la race oui et on part
de loin dans le sens dans le sens
lionel groulx l'appel de la wet devient
un gars de droite
non mais jadis on entendait beaucoup
plus souvent les commentaires comme cet
ordre là beaucoup de mai mais aussi il
faut le débat sur l'identité ce n'est
pas quelque chose de mauvais en soi
toutes les sociétés se questions sur
leur identité sur leur importance
je trouve que
non c'est un fait c'est cet essentiel de
savoir oui nous sommes bien sûr ceux
vers où on veut maintenant hiérarchiser
la 2e levée des droits à cause de ça
mais je pense que parce que des fois
certains de certaines personnes des
camps par d'identité elle se crispe non
mais tu as parfaitement raison c'est ça
un peu le coeur du problème c'est que il
faut avoir à se sentir à l'aise de poser
les visions c'est vrai qu'il faut quand
même faire preuve d'un peu de
sensibilité quand on pose la question
mais pourquoi refuser le fait des forces
on a l'impression que c'est si elle nous
est vu un mot immigration dans sa
question ou quelqu'un d'un groupe
s'explique jamas à s'autocensurer on se
regarde on subit la vérité mais je pense
que c'est ça qui fait qu'ils qui
alimente l'extrême droite
je pense que c'est le fait de ceux que
le sujet de l'identité sont un tabou ça
ça met un grand est où je dire m 2 qui
vient et de l'immigration et des
premières nations
c'est la notion du débat parce que chez
le peuple ici tant anglophones que
francophones dans le canada depuis à
part jusqu'en 1967 debray la notion de
débat n'était pas accepté ce n'est pas
dans les risques d'un mal vu on partait
de même à l'époque il se disait des
choses que dans les années 50 on ne
parle pas à table ok donc voila c'était
en crée même dans les familles dans la
alors on parle de très très loin c'est
une société qui est en train de grandir
apprendre et le débat et le choc des
idées et le partage les idées entre dans
le grand nord de nunavut que son
anniversaire il s'est ressaisi première
consensus au parlement whitehall oui
tout est donc c'est quelque chose par
exemple des choses à apprendre le fils d
autres les médias grand rôle à jouer
aussi dans le véhicule des tic est des
fois dans notre saison va écrire la
droite parce que ces cours on va pas
expliqué vu un détail mais après les
gens ce détraqué ce groupe là on
n'écoute pas c'est la droite
en fait c'est l'ultra droite ouais le
c'est vrai qu'on
quand on est dans l'extrême est dans la
violence
on sort du débat qu'on n'est plus dans
le secteur aux etats-unis et le mot
progressiste
vous êtes un progressiste résidus de
l'institut et de gauche c'est drôle mais
au canada il y avait pendant très
longtemps un parti qui s'appelait les
progressistes conservateurs qui ont été
phagocytée par les conservateurs
aujourd'hui quand l'union entre le
reform l'alliance et les progressistes
consommateur écoute et un bon cours de
géopolitique trafic très agréable de
savoir ici en studio merci beaucoup
raymond des marteaux merci beaucoup
moins cher c'est samir ben merci
stéphane merci les collections là et nos
auditeurs je vous envoie la référence
aux sondages léger avec l'autre merci
pour cette aspiration du sud et pour sa
prochaine